khloe kardashian's latest good american
photo shoot has
people talking and chloe is clapping
back
at all the chatter isn't that crazy it
all started when coco's fashion brand
released
some new campaign images featuring the
keeping up with the kardashians
star cute right well look a little
closer
and you'll see that chloe's feet and
fingers appear to be
totally stretched out i love it while
some fans
loved the unique look of the pics others
questioned if chloe had used photoshop
to achieve the effect
that's when the 36 year old reality star
chimed in tweeting that the whole thing
has her cracking up
explaining that the camera lens they
used elongates
objects that are close to the camera
quote not to worry
i still have normal size hands fingers
oh but she wasn't done not even close
coco added that she's happy with the way
the pics turned out and was shocked
anyone might actually think her feet
were that long
and if all that didn't set the record
straight quote i can't believe i'm even
tweeting this
lol my old hands normal sized hands are
still intact
nope i didn't get a surgery to stretch
my fingers and
nope it's not a photoshop fail have a
great day
she said she hopes the quote concern and
confusion can be put to rest
adding quote this really made me laugh
today thanks for the giggle
no lie i'm gonna figure it all out i
promise you and while these snaps
sparked photoshop speculation
over the weekend chloe sparked
engagement speculation with
this pick yeah fans were quick to point
out that
massive diamond on her ring finger and
chloe playfully reacted to friends and
fans
commenting on both her awesome bod and
the quote
ice rink on her finger but she didn't
comment directly to questions about
whether the photo was her way of
announcing an engagement
as for her boyfriend tristan thompson he
hilariously responded to the shot
writing wow that grass is cut to
perfection
you